[Music]
hey how you doing this is Mel strong and
this lecture is an introduction to
humidity now before we get into humidity
we're going to talk about the
composition of Earth's atmosphere so
this visual here represents the gases
that make up Earth's atmosphere and it
doesn't matter where you are the
composition of the Earth's atmosphere is
pretty much the same no matter where you
go so the atmosphere is about 78%
nitrogen in about 21% oxygen and about
1% argon and right there
you're about 99.9% of all the gases in
the atmosphere there's a little bit of
co2 in a little tiny amount of
everything else so before we go on let's
talk a little bit about these gases
because it's worth knowing a few things
about them so with nitrogen what this
what this visual is is saying is that
right now you've got more nitrogen going
in and out of your lungs than any other
gas so my question is what is it doing
for you and an answer is absolutely
nothing because nitrogen is what we call
an inert gas what that means is that it
really doesn't react with anything and
in order to get nitrogen to react with
something you've got to have really
really high temperatures before any kind
of reactions occur so as it goes in and
out of your lungs you basically your
body just ignores it now it turns out
your body needs nitrogen but it can't
get it this way and that'll come up
later in future lectures so oxygen is
that an inert gas oh no this is very
reactive right and this is why we need
it because it what we call oxidizes and
so we need that for our respiration
process the oxygen accepts electrons and
gets converted in our body from oxygen
to carbon dioxide argon is another inert
gas
and also very heavy so in other words
it's a very dense gas maybe this is one
you haven't heard of before but if you
have seen thermal windows like double
pane windows that are built to insulate
in between the gas they usually put
argon and the reason for that is because
the gas molecules are so heavy they're
really slow and they bump into each
other very slowly and that's how heat is
transferred so they argon gas makes
pretty good insulation then we've got
carbon dioxide and we're gonna talk all
about carbon dioxide much later in the
semester but this is a greenhouse gas so
those gases right there make up
I guess at 99.9% of all of the gases in
the atmosphere so here's another way to
look at that we could break this down
and again you can see that there's
nitrogen at seventy-eight percent oxygen
about 21% argon a point nine percent add
those three together you got 99.9% fact
that's ninety nine point nine five
percent or so and then all these little
traces of gases and some of these you've
heard of maybe some you have it all add
up together so there's a little bit of
other things in the atmosphere however
of all the gases that are shown here
there's one gas that you are breathing
right now
that's in the atmosphere right now and
it's not on this list and that gas is
water water has never shown in a graph
like this or in a list of atmospheric
gases and the reason is water vapor is
considered a variable gas so that means
that it could range from close to zero
all the way up to maybe four percent in
certain parts of the world if you're in
New Mexico it usually ranges from about
zero to maybe close to one percent of
all the gases in the atmosphere so the
reason it's not shown in the graphs that
we've been looking at or the tables you
might find is because all those numbers
have to add up to
and so if I go back to the previous
graph I was just looking at here so all
these numbers add up to exactly 100 so
if I had 2 percent water those numbers
wouldn't add up to a hundred I have to
adjust them all or if I had one percent
water then they wouldn't add up to 100
again and I have to adjust them all so
what they do in all text books and all
references with atmospheric gases as
they call this the dry composition so
dry gas composition of the atmosphere
this is what all the gases of the
composite of the atmosphere would look
like if there were no water but there is
water so you got to take that into
account so that's why they never list
water on these on these tables because
it's always different from day to day
and depends on where you live so
humidity is a way that we describe how
much water vapor is in the atmosphere
and there's several ways to do it
in this lecture we're going to learn two
different ways to describe humidity in
the next lecture we're going to learn
2/3 now the way that would probably make
the most sense to you right now is to
talk about the percentage of gases in
the atmosphere that's water so we just
talked about this how you could have
zero to four percent of the gases in the
atmosphere be water vapor turns out
though that's actually not the way we
usually do it the first method that
we're really going to get into is
something called mixing ratio and mixing
ratio describes how many grams of water
vapor there are in every kilogram of air
and it's often written as a fraction so
here we have mixing ratio equals grams
of water vapor on as a numerator and
kilograms of air as a denominator now
the conventional way to do this is to
think about a single kilogram of air so
I box up some air enough that I have one
kilogram and I want to know in that box
how many grams of water vapor do I have
so that's kind of the way we're going to
think about this so you might see mixing
ratio written something like this mixing
ratio is three grams per kilogram or
three grams per kilogram and the
Assumption here is that you know that
grams means grams of water vapor
kilogramme means kilograms of air okay
now the thing is before we get any
further I want to make sure that we can
visualize what this means what does it
actually like what does a gram of water
vapor look like and what does a kilogram
of air actually look like okay so we're
gonna talk a little bit first about the
metric system so in the metric system
when they were inventing it they said if
you have a cube and the cube is exactly
one centimeter on each side one
centimeter on each side okay one
centimeter by 1 centimeter by 1
centimeter the volume of that is one
cubic centimeter okay and it turns out
if I fill this cube with water that I
will have a mass of exactly one gram so
one gram of water would look like AK you
could fill up a cube that's one
centimeter on each side so what is a
physical object that you can think of
that's about this big so there's a
couple of them I can think of one would
be like a sugar cube what I usually show
everybody or dice so a standard die is
about one centimeter on each side so one
gram of water would look like what
machen if these were little ice cubes
right each one of these would be about
one gram of water so when we talk about
say back to this three grams
the mixing ratios three grams per
kilogram that three grams means three
grams of water vapor think about okay
I'm gonna take water vapor that's in the
air I'm going to condense it down to a
blob and that blob in this case I would
have three of these guys I could fill up
three of these little cubes with water
that way that's what three grams of
water looks like all right so before we
move on to the kilogram of air let's
just talk a little bit more about the
metric system because also when
they came up with a system one cubics in
the centimeter has another name it's
called the milliliter our ml and the end
if you have a thousand milliliters that
equals one liter
okay so that's going to come up here in
a little bit okay so back to our initial
problem I wanted you to be able to
visualize what does this mean this three
grams per kilogram what does that mean
and the top so we've said the top is
three with all ice cubes each the size
of a of a die the bottom I want you to
visualize a box and the box has one
kilogram of air in it and the question
is how big would that box be because we
don't think about air as having much
mass like we we don't even think about
the weight of the air above us but it
has some and so it turns out at our
altitude so here in Albuquerque were
about a mile mile above sea level it
turns out that if you had a box it's
about a meter by meter by a meter that
would be about one kilogram of air okay
see so you fill this up
one meter by one meter by one meter
that's one cubic meter so how big is a
meter think about a doorknob you reach
out to grab a doorknob and the doorknob
is about one meter above the ground okay
so that's a meter so imagine a box that
big on each side that's a kilogram of
air okay so now imagine this box is now
made of plexiglass and so it's plastic
you can see through it and there's a
little door in it okay and we have
filled our box with perfectly dry air
but I'm going to open up the little door
and I'm going to throw in three little
ice cubes okay so I got three grams of
water
I got one kilogram of air I'm gonna open
up the door I'm gonna throw my three
grams of ice in there and close the door
and so my little ice cubes fall to the
bottom of the box and let's say the box
is perfectly sealed and then they melt
so I got for you all the puddles right I
got through though the puddles sitting
here at the bottom of water and then
they evaporate so I come back later and
the these three little puddles have
completely evaporated so the air that's
in there has a mixing ratio of three
grams per kilogram we just made it right
we took a kilogram of air we took three
grams of water we stuck it in there we
let it melt and evaporate and it's
floating around in there and water
molecules by the way the oxygen is
pretty big compared to the hydrogen's
and the hydrogens stick on one side of
it so they look like these Mickey Mouse
heads so you have to kind of imagine
you've got this box now with these
Mickey Mouse heads floating around in
there these all the water molecules
right we'll see more of this in a little
bit okay so imagine I open up the little
door now and let's say I've got a little
cup like a little coffee cup and I reach
in there and a scoop out and I pull out
some of that air what's the mixing ratio
of the air inside my cup it turns out
ratios stay the same they're independent
of size okay so if I take a little bit
of that air the mixing ratio of the
little bit of air that I got out of that
box is still three grams per kilogram
okay so you've got to separate out the
ratios from the absolute amounts of
water so with mixing ratio there's a
number of problems that we can do with
this and I'm gonna work out a couple of
examples here so here's one it says
mixing ratio is four grams per kilogram
how much water do we have total in five
kilograms of air okay so if I show this
problem the people generally half the
people I show this to think that they
should multiply these two numbers and
the other half think they should divide
these two numbers
and neither one can usually give me a
very good reason why so the problems
like this I want you to visualize go
back to thinking about a kilogram of air
as a box a box of air right so I've got
one kilogram of air is a box that we
said was a meter on each side all right
okay so if I one box and the mixing
ratio is four grams per kilogram I have
four grams
inside that box right now if I have five
kilograms I essentially have five boxes
so think about okay so that's one box
but then I got another one right and
then I got another one and so on and so
forth each one of these has four grams
in it so if I've got five of them total
then I can multiply it should make sense
to you that can multiply four times five
for the total amount of water so I'll
write this out with just the unit's here
so I would take my mixing ratio for
grams per kilogram multiply that by the
number of kilograms I have in this case
I have five I'll put that over one and
if I do it if I write it out this way
that unit kilogram cancels that unit
kilogram four times five is 20 and grams
are the units that I have left so by
writing out this way I can see which you
know what I hope is that the unit's that
I don't want to cancel leaving mean the
unit's that I do want that's an
indication that I probably did it right
so I'll do another one
so when this one says the mixing ratio
is 12 grams per kilogram so that might
be a value that we would have here in
the summer during our monsoon season how
much water is in this room okay so let's
just imagine we're in a room and here's
the dimensions of the room five meters
by three meters by 12 meters so what I
need to know to answer this is how many
kilograms of air do I have and I know
that at our altitude here at Albuquerque
one kilogram of air is about one cubic
meter so in order to answer this I need
to know how many cubic meters I have
therefore that will tell me how many
kilograms I have okay so this is a
volume problem and volume is length
times width times height so I'm gonna
take five meters times three meters
times 12 meters and I do that
calculation five times three times 12
I get a hundred and 80 cubic meters okay
so that tells me because one cubic meter
of air is one kilogram that I have a
hundred and eighty kilograms of air in
that room so now it's just like the last
problem I have a hundred and eighty
boxes of air each box has 12 grams of
water vapor in it so to get the total
water I take my mixing ratio and
multiply it by the number of kilograms
of air that I have so again it's like
180 boxes of air each box has 12 grams
in it write it up this way you should
see that units you don't want go away
and they in the unit's you do want are
left so I end up with 12 times 80 I'm
sorry 12 times 180 and that gives me two
thousand one hundred and sixty grams
okay so I want I want you to be able to
visualize what this means okay so this
is the total amount of water so if we
condensed all the water out of the room
right though all the water molecules in
this room we condense it out we would
have two thousand one hundred and sixty
grams well just a minute ago I told you
that so a gram
of water equals one milliliter or one
cubic centimeter right so that's the
same thing as saying two thousand one
hundred and sixty milliliters of water
that's the same thing and can you
visualize what that is
well a thousand milliliters are in a
wieder so two thousand milliliters is
two liters so if I divide this by a
thousand I get two point one six liters
so think of a two liter bottle right we
have filled up a two liter bottle and
we've got a little bit left over that's
how much water we would have if we were
to condense all the water out of this
room on this particular day so let's go
back to this idea of a big plastic box
that we put little ice cubes in and at
the time what I said was we had a little
door on it we could put little these
little ice cubes in there they would
melt then they would evaporate and we'd
have air with some certain kind of
mixing ratio let's imagine we go back to
this box and opened the door and I put
in three more ice cubes and to close it
and they melt and they evaporate and
then I go back and open the door and I
put three more ice cubes and they melt
and they evaporate I could keep going
back and I could keep putting ice cubes
into the door but there comes a point
where if I put too many in there they'll
follow the bottom they'll melt but they
will no longer evaporate because air has
a limit as to how much water vapor can
exist in it in any given time and so we
have a term for this it's called
saturation so what that means if we talk
about the air is reached saturation or
maybe we might say the air is saturated
what that means is that the air can no
longer hold any more water vapor so this
is critical because what this means is
that there's a limit is a limit as to
how much water can be in the air at any
given time now on learn or again if
you're coming here from somewhere else
on my website there is a graph that I
want you now to look at so go ahead and
download that and we're gonna look at
this graph together it's a it's a table
of numbers with a curve looks like this
so this table on the left so the very
left-hand column says air temperature
and fahrenheit in this column here says
maximum possible mixing ratio at this
temperature so what it's showing is that
if it let's say it's 70 degrees and
we've got our plastic box idea right
it's 70 degrees in one kilogram of air
the absolute most water vapor that you
could evaporate into one kilogram of
bear is 19 point 12 grams so this is 19
point 12 grams per kilogram so in one
box of air one kilogram box the this is
the limit as to how much water that air
could hold and you'll notice that as I
increase the temperature the numbers get
higher lower temperatures numbers get
lower and in fact this graph is what you
would get if you were to graph these
numbers it would look like this we got
temperature on the x-axis we've gotten
maximum mixing ratio on the y-axis so
what this is telling us this is actually
one of the most fundamental laws in
weather this idea that temperature
controls how much water could be in the
air at any given time what this is
saying is that if you increase the
temperature you the air could have more
and more water vapor in it it doesn't
mean it has to have that
this is a maximum possible mixing ratio
so let's say it's 80 degrees right so 80
degrees the maximum I could have is 27
grams per kilogram could I have less
than that yes
how much less could I have zero sure I
could have zero but I can't have more
that's what this means notice as you go
down into colder and colder temperatures
the numbers get smaller and smaller or
we get down into this graph let's say
it's zero degrees Fahrenheit here zero
right so at zero the maximum I could
have is about a little over one gram per
kilogram so even if the air saturated
even if it's completely maxed out the
most I could have is a little bit more
than one gram per kilogram so this is
critical because what this means is that
cold air is always dry air even if it's
saturated even if it's completely maxed
out it's still dry I look down here
temperature is a minus 20 minus 40 right
or on this table
you've got really tiny mixing ratios
that are possible so one of the rules
and weather and climate is we're going
to get into is cold air always dry air
always no there's no way around that
however hot air could be humid it could
have high mixing ratios but it doesn't
have to all right so it could be very
low or it could be very high but cold
air absolutely has to be dry air no
matter what all right so we can see the
effects that temperature has on humidity
if we look at the earth as a whole so
I've gone to the site earth null
Schoolnet and this is a visualization
tool that shows us the current weather
all over
and I'm gonna click the word earth and
I'm gonna pick an overlay it says tpw
that's for total precipitable water and
what this is going to show us is it's
going to show us that the how much water
is in the atmosphere mm-hmm and there's
no numbers here but to the left on the
scale the brown that's very very dry air
and then as you get more humidity more
water vapor it turns more blue than
light blue and then kind of this white
color I'm gonna click the word earth to
make that disappear and so I can rotate
the earth around and look at where most
of the water vapor is on the planet and
what I see is that there's this big band
of really high humidity air that that's
typically found around the equator so as
you probably know it's usually pretty
hot at the equator and it's sitting over
this open body of warm water and because
of that the mixing ratios there are
usually very high on the other hand if I
turn this around say we could look at
Arctica and and Arctica is very dry
because it is very cold right and so
both of the poles of the earth are
pretty cold but Antarctica is even more
cold because not only is that the South
Pole the South Pole is about a mile
above sea level so it's much colder than
North Pole and we see it's very Brown
very dry air here but we can also see
some other effects like if I go to let's
go over here to South America and you'll
see that there's this brown blob right
here so I'll zoom in a little bit there
so this is all the amazon basin here so
think about tropical rainforest right so
pretty humid here but what's this why is
this so dry right here so that's a very
tall mountain chain called the Andes and
so high elevation is usually colder
temperatures colder temperatures mean
drier air so we've got
well the really dry air here next to
pretty humid air and we can see this in
several other places in the world and
again if you do this yourself you'll see
slightly different patterns than I'm
seen depending on what time of year
you're looking it's winter in the
northern hemisphere right now so we see
a lot of dry air over the continents the
cold air that's coming down from near
the North Pole so look at someone closer
to home here yeah we're all still pretty
dry here so overall if you just kind of
look at the earth as a whole you will
see that we've got a band of pretty
humid air around the equator and pretty
dry on the north and south poles okay
we're going to do a little thought
experiment here so let's go back to this
idea of having a box of air I got one
kilogram of air and there's water
molecules floating around inside the air
in this box and I happen to know that
the mixing ratio is nine point two four
grams per kilogram okay I also happen to
know that the temperature of the air in
this box is 70 degrees so one question I
could ask could I add more water
molecules to the air inside the box so
if I go to this table and I look at 70
degrees it says the maximum possible
mixing ratio at 17 degrees is 19 point
12 I'm only at nine point two four so I
could definitely add more water to the
air inside this box okay but we're going
to do something different actually we're
gonna cool it down so let's imagine that
I start to cool this box down so it's at
70 and I start to cool down to 65 to 60
to 55 and notice what happens on our
list of numbers here as I go down from
72 65 to 60 to 55 the maximum possible
mixing ratio is also going down right so
if I get down to 50
while 50 the maximum possible mixing
ratio is nine point two four grams per
kilogram which is exactly what I have so
if I cool this down from 70 to 50 when I
get to 50 at that point the air is
saturated it can't hold any more water
vapor okay now let's say I cool it
further so I'm gonna cool it all the way
down to 45 let's say well the maximum
possible mixing wish' at forty five is
seven point six four grams per kilogram
but I'm at nine point two four so as I
cool it down to forty five I've got to
lose about two and a half or so grams of
water so as soon as I get down to 50 in
the air becomes saturated as I COO it
further water molecules have to come out
of the vapor state out of the air and
they will collect on the bottom or the
size of this box
so whether nature requires that all my
little water molecules the extras have
to come out and they will start to
collect in these clusters on the inside
of the box and the transition from the
vapor state to these clusters of liquid
we call that condensation right okay so
condensation occurs at 50 degrees and as
we cool it further and further and
further we will continue to pull water
out of the air as required by the
numbers that are in this table so let me
show this to you a slightly different
way and imagine here I've got just an
image of water molecules here floating
around we don't know how many there are
and it's 80 degrees outside right so I
start to cool it say Sun Goes Down this
is air
outside Sun Goes Down starts to cool and
cools and it cools and it cools and if
it cools enough eventually we're gonna
reach the saturation point and when we
do when we reach that saturation point
and then we continue to COO it further
we would start making condensation so
right here we've got the 65 degrees
we're making condensation this is not
rain this is water that's coming out as
drops on the surface and at that point
they are saturated and what we have just
made is something called do right so
these droplets and I have to show
pictures of this to people that live in
New Mexico because our air is so dry
that this only happens a few times a
year but when it does happen the dew
droplets typically form on the grass and
the reason is because the grass is very
thin and thin things cool off first so
these are do droplets that form one that
when the air was cooled down to the
point that saturation occurs and cooled
even further below that so if we go back
to this idea this temperature at which
this happened in our box this has a name
this is called the dew point temperature
or sometimes because we're lazy we just
call it the dew point so you've actually
done this experiment yourself you've
taken at some point probably leftovers
leftover food you put it in the
Tupperware you put the Tupperware in the
refrigerator and you come back the next
day and you pull it out and when you
take the lid off you'll notice there's a
bunch of little drops on the inside of
the lid that weren't there when you put
the food in the refrigerator so what
happened there is you
when you put it into the refrigerator
the air that was in that container had a
higher mixing ratio than it was allowed
by the temperature of the refrigerator
so you actually may do in that box in
the refrigerator now if we go back to
this case this example here here because
our we notice the condensation occurred
at 65 degrees on this particular night
we could conclude from that that the dew
point temperature was 65 that's when we
still saw condensation first start to
form now let's say I do this another
night and I've got less water vapor to
start with right so there's less water
molecules in the air than there was in
this first example it's 80 degrees again
and I cool it down and I cool it down
and I cool it down the last time we hit
the dew point here but we've got less
water now so that means I can cool it
further before I actually reach
saturation so in this case I cool it all
the way down the 50 degrees until I
finally see that the water molecules
start to condensate out as do so from
here what we could can conclude is that
the dew point is 50 degrees because
that's when condensation occurs so
mixing ratio is one way that humidity is
reported the other way is dew point so
in a weather report they'll often give
the dew point as a way to represent the
humidity in the way that works low dew
point means there's less water vapor in
the air which means the air is pretty
dry high dew point means there's more
water vapor in the air which means that
air has is more generally more humid so
the other way to think about dew point
is that it describes the temperature at
which the atmosphere becomes saturated
so if I tell you let's say tonight I say
we check the weather and the weather
report says the dew point is 45 degrees
one of the bits of information that
tells us
is that if we cool it down the 45
tonight we will get do right we'll we'll
get saturation so here's an example of
how we might use dewpoint so this is a
map and this map has temperatures of dew
points in degrees Fahrenheit and you can
see that over here in the southeast
they've got dew points that are in the
60s and 70s over here in our neck of the
woods we have dew points that are in the
20s so that tells you there's a lot more
water vapor in the air over here then
there is where we live another way to
think about this so if you lived say in
Florida if it got down to the 60s at
night you would get do right because the
dew point here is like 65 here it's 70
if you lived over here you'd have to
have temperatures down below 25 if
you're in the red zone or below 20 if
you're in the yellow zone by the way
what happens when you get dew points
below freezing
if the dew point is below 32 degrees
Fahrenheit or zero degrees centigrade
then that means that in order to get do
you've got to get it below freezing but
you're not going to get liquid what
you'll get is frost and frost looks the
same it's little sparkles on the grass
at night that's when the dew point is
below freezing and you manage to cool it
below freezing but it's the same idea
and in the winter this is a lot more
common you may have scraped ice off your
windshield that's what's happening
it's you've reached saturation but the
saturation point was below freezing and
your windshield is thin you know cools
off first another way that we actually
use dew point a lot in New Mexico is to
monitor the monsoon and we'll talk about
the monsoon in later lectures but this
is something called the dew point
tracker and so if you look at this on
the x-axis these are dates there's June
first and then there's July 1st and the
ignore everything except the blue line
for
the blue line is the dew point as
recorded at the airport here in
Albuquerque so when the blue numbers are
higher you have more water vapor in the
air you have higher dew points then
you'll see them drop that's low dew
points dew dew points are over here on
the on the y axis so here we got dew
points of like maybe five degrees
Fahrenheit they don't have units but
these are units of Fahrenheit so we had
really dry air right through here then
it got more humid then they got a little
bit drier then they got more humid again
and goes back and forth back and forth
but notice that once we get into July we
have pretty high dew points for almost
the entire summer
now this graph stops in August 22nd
which is when they made this one look
for a minute at the red curve the red
curve is what you get if you were to
average out all of the monsoons that
have happened in the past 30 years and
if you do so on average in Albuquerque
what happens is the dew point starts to
rise in the spring and once it rises
past this Green Line this Green Line is
47 degrees it rises past this this Green
Line for three consecutive days we
declare that the monsoon has officially
started and then on average again we're
looking at the red one on average the
red line stays above this green line and
it starts to dip back below the Green
Line in the middle of September and then
we go into the fall so dew point is one
of the things that we use to monitor the
monsoon activity when we have high dew
points that's usually coincides with
what we call monsoon bursts we have a
lot of there's a lot of humidity in the
air a lot of water in the air and so
that's more conducive to precipitation
formation so when you see these spikes
here those are times when we probably
had more thunderstorms and more chances
of precipitation or sometimes we go into
what are called monsoon breaks and
that's what this is
so this dip here is a period where we
were in a very dry spell ative ly dry
air for the monsoon period and during
that time we probably saw very few of
any cumulonimbus very few thunderstorms
during that time so dew point is pretty
important here in New Mexico especially
during the monsoon season so dew point
is reported at pretty much all weather
stations report dew point it changes
throughout the year so in New Mexico
it's typically higher in the summer and
lower in the winter and one of the other
things that can change dew point
especially where we live is the wind
direction so we happen to live between
you know New Mexico's here and we've got
a pretty warm body of water down here
and we have a pretty cold body of water
over here right so let's say we've got
wind coming from the northwest where did
that wind come from well it came from
somewhere to the north where was
probably cold and cold air is always dry
air dry air low dew point so we have
wind's coming out of the West or the
north of the Northwest usually that
coincides with times of low dew point on
the other hand if the wind comes out of
the east or the southeast that's coming
from a location that was pretty warm big
warm body of water that's usually
conducive to high amounts of water vapor
in the air so usually for us if we have
wind that comes out of the East or the
southeast we usually get higher dew
points because we have more water in the
air
you